[موسيقى]
بنسبه 100% من اصوات اعضاء مجلس النواب
الشعب فاز شيمبيين بولايه ثالثه رئيسا
للصين فوز متوقع بعد التعديل الدستوري عام
2018 الذي الغى الشيى بموجبه محدوديه فتره
الرئاسه لولايتين فقط ما يفتح الباب امامه
لرئاسه مدى الحياه وخلال الادلاء بالقسم
اكد الشي على العمل لبناء دوله اشتراكيه
وديمقراطيه
اقسم ان اكون مخلصا لدستور جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه
وان اعمل بجد لبناء دوله استراكيه حديثه
وديمقراطيه ومتحضره
جدد مجلس النواب الشعب ايضا ثقته في
الرئيس شي من خلال اعاده انتخابه على راس
اللجنه العسكريه المركزيه وهو ما يعادل
منصب القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
الصينيه بعد عشر سنوات في السلطه يعزز
الرئيس
مكانته بفتره رئاسيه ثالثه قد تساهم في
تعميق النفوذ الصيني اقليميا وعالميا من
خلال مبادرات طموحه يعمل عليها شيك
كمبادره الحزام والطريق للاستثمار في
الدول الاخرى مبادره ينظر اليها الغرب على
انها مستنقع من الديون ستغرق فيه دول
فقيره منها بلدان افريقيه استثمارات صينيه
بمليارات الدولارات في البنيه التحتيه
للدول الناميه تتهم بيجين بانها تحاول
الحصول من خلالها على موطئ قدم لها في
الموانئ الرئيسيه لهذه الدول وتوسيع
نفوذها الجيو السياسي بانشاء قواعد
عسكريه صينيه في كمبوديا وغيرها
خلال السنوات الخمس الماضيه احرزت الصين
انجازات سواء عالميا من خلال مبادره
الحزام والطريق او محليا من خلال السيطره
على الوضع الفوضوي في هونج كونج السيطره
على الوضع درس لتايوان حول ضروره الالتزام
بسياده القانون
اقليميا يبقى ملف اعاده ضم تايوان
والسيطره على الشارع في هونغ كونغ من ابرز
الملفات التي يتعامل معها الرئيس سوشي
فبعد اخماد احتجاجات عام 2019 في هونج
كونج عمل على تعزيز ولاء الحكومه المحليه
هناك لبيجين احتجاجات كانت تنادي بتعزيز
الحريات والديمقراطيه لكنها انتهت
باعتقالات ومحاكمات بموجب قانون جديد
للامن القومي شيماء تويي الجزيره بيجيم